hey everybody it's the wacky gamers okay
Adams lame but it's us it's Jeff and
Adam I'm Adam and we're here to do
another versus video yes we are a lot of
people seem to like them so we're gonna
keep going but this time it's another
user suggestion keep posting user
suggestion yes let's go let's say some
of the use of suggestions that they sent
us Jeff okay so one of the ones they
gave us was Harry Potter versus Percy
Jackson it's kind of interesting that
was boga Donny yet we decided it would
end up in the make-out session the next
one mr. freezer should Sub Zero that was
from exam that was pretty good idea but
we decided that they're just too icy
cold for us but it was cool idea thank
you for posting it and the last one we
wanted to call out then we won't do but
we thought was cool is mega van versus
punisher that was interesting he's
injured we argued about it for a while
and then ended up in a cockfight and
Mega Man would win
the one we're gonna do today also from
ex nemesis kratos version store but
before that i want to talk about what
happened the last time so i did we did
bowser versus the hope bowser versus the
whole in a tell him what we found out
about the whole Jeff's argument for why
Bowser would win was basically centered
around the fact that the Incredible Hulk
can get hurt by fire well unfortunately
Stanley listen to our podcast not really
someone who knows Stanley listen alright
and Stan and and Stan said the Hulk is
immune to fire yeah the fireballs from
the what I said okay so we're gonna give
that one to the Hulk Hulk wins
regardless of the comments we're just
gonna have to throw one out
Iron Man vs Master Chief was much more
debated the user spoke and it seems that
Master Chief has the edge especially if
you consider Tony Stark and Master Chief
outside of there there
I wouldn't say costumes with their armor
their armor yeah anyway now on to the
task at hand
alright Thor versus Kratos Thor versus
craters you guys take video games again
I'm gonna take comic well this time
they're gonna win heartily again like
Master Chief
let's let's hear it you go ahead and
throw down the gauntlet no I want to
hear your coal Fred you wanna hear you
wanna hear my bowl crap
go ahead all right well uh Thor as we
all know god of thunder
you mean Fabio and a Viking helmet see
you're gonna interrupt me when I'm
talking
first off Fabio is a strongman did you
see him hit like if Thor can take a
goose to the face the same way Fabio did
no question about it
Thor wins if Fabio took a dick to the
face like Thor does no doubt Kratos is
gonna kick his ass Thor has never taken
addictive the face Thor is so powerful
he once reconstructed the moon can you
say that about Kratos wouldn't help you
in a fight sure you'd make a moon and
then you throw it at somebody but you
gotta make the moon meanwhile Kratos
just sliced your head off Thor has the
hammer of the gods of exile blades of
Exile boob whatever the hammer of the
cuts you've got one hammer of a god it's
a freaking hammer
I mean seriously could you come up with
a lamer it's been no sharp edges just a
war hammer a blunt object actually the
back of the hammer it has a blade on it
not in any picture I ever saw yeah I'm
gonna probe some old picture picture
picture picture picture yeah well you're
so an old picture old picture old face
so we're not we're not counting the
Johanna logic sure Kratos never had a
lame weapon hmm not a single lame weapon
he took the weapons from every God
Pantheon God every God he's got the
power of Hermes which is kind of good I
will say but he's he's the God of War
okay so so it's all purpose in life is
to kick some ass so your argument is
that he has the power of Hermes no all
me know that he can run fast got the
blade of abusing the thing here's the
thing with running fast actually Thor is
so fast he was able to build trenches
before Quicksilver the fastest Marvel
character could get there it doesn't
matter BAM he's faster than Quicksilver
and I'll tell you this what are we gonna
do for you when Kratos just whipped your
ass it calls the spirits of the Dead and
just kicked your ass here's a
little-known fact Thor is like the most
powerful Marvel character
there is he's the [ __ ] closest thing
that's a clue break toast is the most
badass video game character of all time
well no doubt he is he killed every
Greek god
and it's been killed multiple times and
crawled his ass back out of Hades and
just whoop some more ass oh if we're
gonna talk about being killed while
sometimes every single Marvel character
has been killed multiple more needs to
eat golden apples to be immortal Kratos
just that it stays a matte or mortal
forever
well you know what held in apples how
[ __ ] you then you know what you know
what I got half way that I win no you
don't here's why you don't win because
halfway through the fight with Thor
Kratos would have to stop and solve a
stupid boring puzzle that he can't
figure out because the camera angle
never changes Thor wins yeah you think
the Thor games gonna be any better hmm
the Thor game is gonna be flawless the
freakin movie which is gonna be terrible
because that's how most comic book
movies end up I don't know if you saw
the daredevil movie wait a minute but no
wait a minute there's a model good
cowboy terrible you know would be a
terrible movie
Kratos god of war the movie no wouldn't
yes it would no it wouldn't yes it would
be as good as the Resident Evil movie
exactly that's what I said Kratos would
just be gasps his sole purpose in life
he doesn't care about other people he
could care less if he destroys the
planet and destroying Thor what Thor
would be all someone's gonna get hurt
one of my poor Nordic [ __ ] is going
to get hurt Kratos no go ahead and kill
the [ __ ] no here's a here's the thing
Kratos has no friends and no allies
whereas Thor has the entire pantheon he
does the monkey friends are managers cuz
he kills them on Steel's the powers of
Thor had any cojones he would have
killed all the Avengers and taken their
powers look I've played God of War three
the powers aren't really that useful the
weapons are the most useful thing the
powers kind of suck the weapons are
took from all the other guns that you
clearly didn't play the game I played
the game you from Hermes to get running
yeah and from a bow and arrow
okay he also [ __ ] Aphrodite I'm just
saying he did [ __ ] Aphrodite that was
weeks yeah all right so we're agreeing
it was Kratos okay Kratos gets more
action but I think Thor would win I'd
totally disagree yeah me too
Kratos killed all the way of course of
course the first row he was gonna win
these arguments and well you know I had
to put up a fight
but seriously he's killed every guy you
know okay well we'll have another one
don't forget to post uh I know this
ending is kind of lame but don't forget
to post the ones you want down below we
will get to them we will argue them
stupidly just like we do these one mm-hm
and we will call out your goodness if
you post them in we decide not to argue
to bring you gimme gimme I still think
Gord win actually Adam likes Fabio cause
he kind of game you just have sympathy
for bald people
[Laughter]
you
[Music]